um okay let's go to our caller from the
let's go to the six one two area code
who's calling today from six one two oh
yeah that's you who's this my name is
Stefan hi Dave hey how you doing great
man
uh well where do I start first off thank
you so much for just being out there and
just giving an informative kind of
opinion you know like a lot of times you
get like a newscast and you feel like
all weird vibe from them but with you
like I really feel like you're trying to
give the truth out there and trying to
give an honest answer and I love thank
you
appreciate it my pleasure okay so here's
what what's up so obviously like I was
always into politics growing up was on
the debate team
um and definitely knew like Republicans
like they voted because like they
thought God was appointing their
official team stuff okay so I always had
a hard time trying to follow Republican
views because a lot of times when I had
my friends they'd be like I'm Republican
because it's the right choice and
there's always this schema of the right
thing so I just recently started dating
girl for about we've been dating for a
year and it's great you know and she's
always like you're super into politics
and I just don't get that come to find
out like her father was super religious
and they really tied in the fact that
they were religious and Republican and
that those two were tied together okay
and now it's been a year and she's and
I'm progressive by the way like straight
progressive like I want everything needs
to change you know like the system is
broken you know it's out for
money-making schemes and there's things
that need to change and I want to hear
plans to do so so she isn't way more
open nowadays with the way I see things
because she just sees the practicality
of making things better for the right
reasons you know what I mean and
nowadays she likes to admit that being
being her views Republican and religion
were tied together that she saw being in
the Republican Party as a religious cult
and we just saw entertain that idea
nowadays and trying to talk to others
and try to come to a table because like
you definitely have opened my eyes to
that as like maybe I don't have to see
their views but like we should at least
encourage the conversation what I'm
trying to bring up today is where do you
separate for them their passion for
their God which I have to honor because
I don't have a way to disprove them
their passion for their God with their
connection to politics like I do I
should I just write it off that they're
religious and that they're going to have
their views no matter what or is there a
way that can I have a conversation with
them that they can start seeing me is
not just the bad guy but somebody who
wants to have a progressive agenda okay
so listen there's a bunch of different
start here so just for context yeah I'm
a my right that I'm guessing from your
accent you're from like the northern
Midwest somewhere is that where all this
is going on oh sure okay
no you're not thrown anything I'm just
trying to understand I I gathered that
that must be the part of the country
you're talking about so so are you like
what in Wisconsin Minnesota something
like that
I I'm born Wisconsin but moved to the
Twin Cities so now I reckon City I so it
correct me if I'm wrong but the
Republicans in that area it's these are
not like Kentucky evangelicals right
you're talking about a different type of
religiosity you would be that is such a
great point to make out because here
it's more of like a cloak like you don't
really see it as right off the bat it's
more you get to know somebody and then
three days of getting to know someone
you find out they're devout Christian
were you like Kentucky you kind of see
it more write off the off the cuff ya
know so listen here's my advice and take
it take it for what you're paying for it
which is nothing right I I don't know
first of all you said you you have to
respect their God because you can't
disprove it I think that that's the
wrong approach I think that you don't
have to respect their their God any more
than anything else that no one else can
prove and what I mean by that is
they are free to believe anything they
want privately their religion can be
valuable to them in whatever ways it's
valuable to them but it's okay to set a
line and say your arbitrary self
professed beliefs have no place in
figuring out what policy should be in a
country that has separation of church
and state so first of all I don't know
that I would be as deferential to the
religious component is maybe you're
suggesting now of course this is your
girlfriend's family you don't want to
alienate them either but what what what
I would try to do is I don't know that I
would be slicing and dicing things into
which views are informed by religion and
which or not I would just speak about
your progressive values because those
are positive values those are values
that bring good things to the table for
people and I don't think you should put
yourself in a position to have to
present your progressive views as a
counter or alternatively to their
religiosity absolutely you know we
always will have that talk and they'll
kind of throw their heart about out you
know and you feel that kind of love for
it and then you just and what I usually
do is just file a you know like there's
flat-out an amendment that says there
will be a separation of church and state
right and you you know like obviously
it's it's ballsy to say this to somebody
you know but the way you pointed out it
makes it a lot easier to go about in the
next day is why why should I lose my
progressive agenda just because this
person's getting emotional of something
I can't just agree with him on so but
step ahead are mostly interested in are
have there been arguments with her
family because they are right-wingers
and you're a left winger
well we haven't even come to the table
about where we sit like her her father
my girlfriend and I have had this
conversation and I've had to talk to her
her friends who are Republicans and I
even Maga supporters which I would even
I separate that group from yeah yeah you
know what I mean yeah I separate them
from Republicans because there's
Republicans who I want to talk about
their values and and figure that out and
then there's the dude who was wearing
the Hat and screaming like it's a foot
all game right I don't care about that
guy my gosh
alright Stefan listen it sounds like
quite a situation you have going there
appreciate the call and you know let me
know how it goes with them absolutely
alright thanks very much take care